[Music]
welcome to the google cloud marketplace
private catalog the private catalog is a
service on google cloud allowing cloud
admins to control distribution of
solutions ensure compliance and
governance and make solutions easily
discoverable within their organization
so what does that really mean an admin
at a company wants to ensure that the
platform's group has access to a set of
cloud solutions some solutions are
custom to the company and others are
solutions they've purchased on google
cloud and they need to be curated by
region by team and different criteria
your organization needs
the way they do this is creating a
catalog instance add solutions to it and
share it with the group of users not
only is it shared private catalog can
ensure that the solution is configured
and ready to deploy or use all in one
place
cloud admins can manage a central place
for end users to find approved solutions
admins have the ability to push
solutions with the latest patches or
versions end users don't have to worry
about what's being deployed and can be
assured that they're always using the
latest and greatest version of every
approved solution
admins can use templates to add
parameters for users they can place
limits on who can deploy resources and
which resources they can deploy
and finally we've made it easy for
admins to take third party solutions
from google cloud marketplace and add
them to their private catalog
we're going to explore the admin view
first which right now is in the zero
state with no catalogs or solutions we
can get started on changing that by
clicking go to catalog manager or manage
solutions on the left side navigation
bar
let's go ahead and create a new solution
start by clicking solutions in the left
navigation bar and then create solution
the private catalog supports three
solution types terraform configs links
and deployment manager
terraform is a tool for building
changing and versioning cloud
infrastructure safely and efficiently
terraform configs are a way to deploy
first party google cloud services but
using terraform
link solutions are really just a url
this could be to documentation or
whatever it is that you need to point to
links work for sas solutions such as a
pointer to mongodb's product offering on
google cloud marketplace
deployment manager solutions are used to
deploy any google cloud first party
service including storage vms containers
or bigquery
for this example we'll select terraform
config
a form will appear on the right side of
the screen the top six fields are
consistent across all solution types
starting with name and description and
also including a tagline for the browse
page of the private catalog an icon
support information and a link to any
relevant documentation
after that we need to add a link to the
terraform config this one is called
google cloud storage and it points to a
zip file in a gcs bucket gs terraform
samples gcsbucket.zip
the zip file should include your
terraform configs
once we've attached the zip file hit
create and this adds the solution to the
private catalog
a process that takes a couple seconds if
you're wondering what's happening in the
back end the system is leveraging cloud
build to run terraform validate and
parse out the input definitions for the
product
while that's happening the solution will
appear in the table and you can click on
it to review the information that was
added earlier
validation status will remain as pending
while the solution is being processed
after which it should change to valid
let's add a send grid email api link
solution
again click solutions in the left
navigation bar
followed by create solution in the bar
above the table
you can also add a deployment manager
solution click create solution in the
bar above the table
enter basic metadata for the solution
and attach a zip file for the solution
this wordpress deployment manager
template was downloaded from the
wordpress solution page available in the
marketplace
now let's create a catalog
first head to catalogs using the left
navigation bar a catalog is really just
a grouping of products and the way to
make your products available to end
users is by creating a catalog adding
solutions to it and then sharing that
catalog with a part of your
organization's google cloud hierarchy
when creating catalogs you may want to
group solutions by region by disciplines
like development or testing or really
whatever makes sense for your company
you can create as many catalogs as you
need
hit the create catalog button the form
prompts us to add a catalog id and a
description this catalog is called
devtools with the descriptor development
tools
click create to finish setting up the
catalog
the new catalog appears in the catalogs
table
now that we've created a catalog we can
assign it a solution click into the
catalog we've just created
in the details page click on assign
solutions
find the google cloud storage solution
we created earlier and press assign
let's go back to the catalogs page using
the back button at the top and add one
more catalog so we can see how they work
together we can name this one test tools
with the descriptor testing tools
once the testing catalog is saved we can
assign the link solution to it
now that we have two catalogs each
containing solutions it's time to share
them with the right users in the google
cloud hierarchy
head back to catalogs page and select
the two catalogs we've created go to
share from the options at the top and
from here you can choose to share the
catalog at the organization folder or
project level we're going to share both
catalogs at the project level with a
project called product manager
everyone in the google cloud hierarchy
with access to that project will now see
and have access to the solutions within
the catalog
we are now going to click browse catalog
on the top right side of the screen to
take a look at the end user view
let's go ahead and filter by the catalog
we created earlier devtools
this brings up our terraform config
google cloud storage clicking on the
solution loads the details page a page
that is similar across all three types
of solutions in the private catalog
this makes it easy for end users to
quickly find solutions they can use
now let's deploy our terraform config
click deploy to begin the new deployment
here we will fill out the input
variables needed for the deployment
for terraform configs we also have
something like a pre-flight check when
we click preview and deploy the system
will start to run terraform plan in the
background this happens without having
to install terraform get the binaries or
anything else these services are
abstracted from you and the end user
allowing you to easily deploy the
solutions you need
in this case terraform plan has run
successfully so we can go ahead and
deploy the solution
in this case we will create a gcs bucket
once the deployment has successfully
completed the icon turns green this
usually takes a few minutes but it does
depend on the solution you are deploying
let's take a look at a situation where
the deployment has failed clicking the
deployment shows the logs enabling the
user to potentially self-service and fix
the issue
with our solution successfully deployed
we can go back to the private catalog
home page and browse all terraform
deployments using the tab in the left
navigation bar
the private catalog gives organizations
a single place to discover approved
solutions that they can deploy knowing
the solutions have been approved and
verified by their cloud admin
it also looks a lot like the google
cloud marketplace and for a reason we've
aimed to create a consistent ui
experience to help you and your users
easily navigate and enjoy the benefits
of the private catalog
ready to get going begin building on
google cloud with 300 in free credits
and 20 plus always free products get
started today